ma con qualcuno tu lastra di ghiaccio e
quel cazzo di none parlante narnia di
merda pelle a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi
il nuovo blog con ragazzi volevo
ringraziarvi veramente tantissimo non
solo per il traguardo dei 175.000 che
ormai sono 176 mila e passa ma volevo
ringraziarvi perché personalmente a me
quel il video che è uscito ieri come
speciale non era piaciuto tantissimo non
nel senso che fosse brutto ma nel senso
che potevo uscire molto molto meglio
perché purtroppo avevo dei mezzi
limitati ma nonostante questo ragazzi
l'avete apprezzato tantissimo avete dato
mi avete fatto tantissimi complimenti e
io ragazzi veramente
sono senza parole perché comunque dio ci
spendo tanto per fare i video e sapere
che nonostante una cosa poteva uscire
meglio la solidarietà che avete nei miei
confronti è qualcosa di fantastico
ragazzi siete sede non ho parole per
descrivervi siete fantastici veramente
ragazzi voi mi dite ogni volta favi ma
ti sei mai sognato di arrivare un
traguardo del genere io no ragazzi ma
non è quello l'importante la cosa che
non mi sarei mai aspettato e arrivare a
un traguardo del genere con degli
iscritti
così i fantastici ragazzi adesso passerò
per i leccaculo di turno ma vi giuro che
mi avete dato una gioia che non vi posso
descrivere grazie grazie grazie
pochi ragazzi le solite promesse di
mezz'ora le ho fatte perché se no non è
un video che si rispetti
quindi direi che possiamo iniziare con
il video vero e proprio con il blog vero
e proprio e indovinate un po a raga da
oggi iniziano i blogs eric cosa vuol
dire blog seri che da adesso in avanti
tutti i blog saranno strutturati in
questo modo fra l'arte della settimana
news del canale apertura dei pacchi che
ci saranno eventualmente e risposta dei
commenti che mi lascerebbe sotto ogni
blog e ovviamente il fa vi risponde
quindi ragazzi da oggi in avanti vedrete
un format diverso per i blog e spero che
vi piaccia fatemelo sapere comunque nei
commenti
e direi di iniziare subito prima che il
blog duri anni è la fan art della
settimana ragazzi è stata vinta da
antonio che ha fatto un praticante un
ritratto di meco gli occhiali sono
praticamente identico cioè ragazzi
guardate che roba
ok va bene ragazzi direi che possiamo
passare alle news del canale e che è il
secondo punto dei blog è la cosa che mi
dispiace tantissimo e che devo prima di
inaugurare i nuovi il nuovo format dei
blog
partendo con una news che non è non è
bellissima purtroppo ragazzi e la news è
la seguente la praticamente la maggior
parte di coloro che mi seguono
sono ragazzi ovvero studenti tutti
coloro che vanno a scuola sanno che
ultimamente c'è negli ultimi giorni le
scuole sono iniziate quasi per tutti se
non rinizieranno tra pochissimo per
tutti quanti visto che quest'anno io ho
la maturità e quindi come tale la devo
prendere seriamente perché la scuola è
importante ragazzi quest'anno ragazzi
devo dedicare molto più tempo allo
studio perché avendo la maturità o le ho
le mie responsabilità la rima non è
voluta durante quest'anno ragazzi non vi
garantisco che avrò una continuità come
quella che ho sempre avuto io ve lo dico
non vi preoccupate farò comunque un
video al giorno vi sto dicendo che ogni
tanto salterò e magari un giorno non
farò un video magari anche più di uno
due o tre consecutivi potrà accadere
ragazzi capiterà di sicuro comunque
ragazzi questa non è l'unica music e
volevo dirvi ma penso che abbiate notato
che ultimamente mi sto orientando quasi
al cento per cento su su serie horror
ovvero outlast amnesia girone sono
speciale le rose lander
questo perché ultimamente c'è nelle
settimane scorse per la mente di horror
non ne faceva proprio
e l'ideale sarebbe fare sia serie
divertenti sia oro però non si sa perché
quando esco professore divertenti non
c'è un horror manco a pagarlo
quando ci sono gli horror non ci sono
giochi divertenti manco a pagarlo tranne
è più visto e just dance nonostante
questo state tranquilli che l'essere
divertenti tornerà
il prima possibile quindi ragazzi piove
prima news ovviamente vi ho dovuto dire
la valanga che di solito non saranno
così tante ve lo dico subito però è
questo è stato un caso speciale direi di
passare allo scart aggio del pacco
giornaliero ragazzi vi voglio dire che
in questa prima settimana nel quale ho
aperto punto basta c'è stato un boom di
pacchi assurdo quindi ragazzi non aprirò
una blog se non vedete il vostro parco
che la pro in questo blog magari no però
nel prossimo se non è il prossimo in
quello dopo ancora comunque state
tranquilli che quelli che li ha prodotti
e direi di passare al pacco di oggi
ragazzi allora ne ho scelto un in
particolare penso che capirete il perchè
perché ho scelto questo perchè mi occupa
tutor [ __ ] comodino ragazzi io vorrei
capire che cos'è sta roba
un televisore al plasma cosa cioè è il
più grande devo aprire assolutamente
questo perché è con questa roba in casa
e l'apprendimento e non posso camminare
è quindi direi di darci sotto madonna
santissima che cazzola impacchettato
stoppa con fbi
ma allora c'è un'apertura che devo
chiamare james bond per aprirlo alla
tematica finalmente cosa cazzo a ragazzi
mi avete inviato dei pezzi di giornale
fa beach per il ragazzo più grosso del
mondo più grosso danno della al mondo fa
vj da john elisabetta e ilaria ragazzi
poi la l'immondizia me le ha buttate
moglie giovanna che poiché poi io devo
anche pulire in camera mi avete inviato
una pizza
grazie mille sentite e non è che fredda
perché magari il pacco lo tengo lina una
settimana forse si apre data ma forse
anche no con la pizza direttamente da
giovanni muciaccia cassetto pronto pizza
che
notti e fantastico grazie finite perché
questa epica non vedete che cazzo mi
avete inviato o mio dio non ci credo non
ci posso credere
un guasto dentro un altro pacco ragazze
ma mettere tutto in un parco di riuscire
a tanto difficile comunque se un altra
roba il parcheggio è pantana devo
scaldare l'opa su nuova ma inquadrata le
scatole prima o poi avrà vana fine
ragazzi ve lo giuro ve lo farò io ve lo
prometto
finiremmo questa cosa
[Musica]
di quella [ __ ] quella [ __ ] di
quella [ __ ] quella [ __ ] se cioè
cos'è sta roba sla che cos'è cos'è cos'è
raga colletta è una cosa e un supporto
cd cd finto uccide finto ma che cazzo
due ore e mezza di scartato per un cd
pinto e c'è pure che mario mio dio
comunque sia guadagnato una medaglia
come the best di youtubers ed ha perciò
c'è scritto un po vj king suo record
quindi il guinness record per aver
scartato il pacco più impacchettato al
mondo con che ragazzi vi ringrazio per
la pizza
il ct le lettere la medaglia da giggs
record e non solo ma vi ringrazio anche
perché ho scoperto che i tarallucci sono
in offerta
va bè ragazzi mi mi farete sclerare da
morire vi giuro lo so io lo so perché vi
conosco maledette direi di passare alle
domande ragazzi alla prima domanda è
fatta da in mart 94 falli risponde il
tuo supereroe marvel preferito il mio
supereroe marvel preferito è ovviamente
super fa vj che rimette il supereroe che
aiuta coloro che sono inseguiti dai cat
mario in spiaggia antonius 000 fa
risponde favi fai dei vivi dei b days
non bidoni dei più lunghi magari facendo
meno tagli
allora ragazzi sta cosa che ve l'avevo
già spiegato in passato io taglio tanto
nei video per rendere il tutto più
scorrevole molto più godibile taglio
tutte quelle scene che sono che reputo
inutili o comunque scene non belle la
maggior parte di quello che faccio
consiste in questo io non ci metterei
mai sei ore per farlo perché poi vi
chiedete come farfa dj a metterci sei
ore per fare un video proprio perché
taglio tanto io ve lo dico sempre
ragazzi piuttosto che mettere un video
che non mi piace e che può non piacere
io non l'ho carico o ai miei video sono
assolutamente perfetti olio non carico
nulla ragazzi sono sempre stato di
questa filosofia mi conosce chi mi
conosce da tempo lo sa
ci tengo così tanto a curare nei minimi
dettagli ogni video che faccio è per
questo anche che faccio tanti tagli favi
ti rechi il gomito con la lingua
si no ancora
[Musica]
come risponde nel duo intimo cecili
ai ragazzi le domande e finiscono qui
come al solito il 6 blog vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
tra tana descrizione non se la crisi
figli iscrivetevi riusciti vediamo un
prossimo vivo ragazzi